PROFESSOR: So we've
just discussed
how inertia and buoyancy forces
can destabilize the fluid
and lead to complex
flows of air in a room.
But now, let's think
about how those flows will
influence the transport
of aerosol droplets
which transmit disease.
So maybe a simpler
way to think about it
is imagine we have
some object which
is releasing a
substance which could
be particles containing virus.
It could also be heat or
other chemical release.
And that's in a flow field
similar to the types of flow
fields that we've
been discussing.
So that's the problem of
forced or natural convection,
convective transport
of particles.
So here I show the problem
of flow past a cylinder.
And let's say the cylinder
is a hot cylinder, which
is releasing heat into the fluid
which I've kind of sketched
by this red region here.
Now if the flow is fast compared
to the diffusion of heat,
you would expect a
situation like this
where there's a thin
boundary layer of heat
transfer along the
front end of the sphere.
But on the trailing
end, there might
be a wake of kind
of hot fluid that's
been kind of carried away.
And that is indeed
what happens when
we're in the regime of dominance
of convection over diffusion.
And there is a dimensionless
which describes that,
which is the Peclet number.
So the Peclet number is defined
as the velocity times a length
scale divided by D where D
that is the mass diffusivity.
Now normally, D is the
molecular diffusivity.
Or it's the diffusivity
or let's say the droplets
or whatever the
individual particles are.
Now, if you want to think
about diffusion of gas--
so if we have for gas
molecules-- for example,
like for CO2 or
oxygen in the air,
then the ratio of
kinematic viscosity
to diffusivity of
the gas molecules,
that's called the
Schmidt number,
is also around 0.7 for air.
So basically
molecules of momentum
are diffusing at
about the same rate.
And so that tells us that
for the molecules of the gas,
the Peclet number is actually
the same as the Reynolds number
and, in fact, is very large.
If we have a larger object
such as maybe a droplet,
we have, of course, much
lower diffusivity than the air
molecules.
And we're not talking and
it's a different process
on a collisional.
But we're still dealing with
very large Peclet numbers
which will lead
to kind of wakes,
as I've just described here.
So it depends on the details
and the size of the particles.
But for the gas, I
just want to write here
that Peclet number is on the
same order as the Reynolds
number and hence is very much
larger than 1 in many cases.
Now the thing is that because
the Peclet number is 1,
the Peclet number is
measuring the importance
of convective
transport to diffusion.
And so because the Peclet
number is typically large,
we have a dominance
of convection
over diffusive process.
So think of our
aerosol droplets.
They do diffuse in the air.
And we can calculate that
with the same Stokes-Einstein
formula that we've used earlier.
But that diffusion
rate is very slow
compared to the sort
of convective processes
that are occurring in the room.
And so we typically have
a high Peclet number
and we see this
kind of behavior.
On the other hand, we're also
in the regime of high Reynolds
number.
And that really changes things
because then the diffusion
due to sort of random
fluctuations and collisions
with other molecules is
overwhelmed by the sort
of transport and
diffusion light transport
that follows from
vortices and turbulence.
So if I take that
same cylinder and I
at now at a higher
Reynolds number,
then we can see that the wake
is not a thin little tail that
extends downstream
but it's really
a turbulent wake where the
warm fluid in this case
is dispersed everywhere
throughout that wake.
In fact, it's fairly
uniformly mixed.
A similar situation occurs
in the case of breathing,
coughing, sneezing, and other
forms of respiration, which
we will come to
shortly, where we
have a relatively high Reynolds
number flow, often turbulent,
and we are injecting in it some
respiratory aerosol particles.
And they're quite well
mixed across that jet.
So we can see there's
a very strong coupling
between the fluid flow
that we've just discussed,
which is often turbulent and
containing vortices and eddies,
and the transport of suspended
particles and droplets.
So how can we think
about this problem?
So the important
thing is when we
get into this turbulent
regime, the way
an individual particle--
imagine-- I should think
even here in this case.
How does an individual
particle move?
It kind of follows the flow.
So it goes first through
a little vortices
occasionally around
a big vortex,
and then it does
some little ones.
And so it's also
doing a random walk
but it's one that's driven
by the turbulent flow itself.
And the length
scale for the sort
of steps of the random walk
is actually the vortex size.
And in particular,
it's dominated
by the largest vortex.
So whatever the flow
is, there's always
a certain scale which sets the
size of the largest vortex.
And so that leads to the concept
of so-called eddy diffusivity
in turbulent flows, which is
also important in air flows.
So the eddy diffusivity is
an effective diffusion-like
parameter that describes
the mixing and spreading
of suspended particles or
droplets in a flow field that
is turbulent.
And in that case, we
can write it two ways.
So either we have an
imposed velocity u
and we have length scale l,
and then our eddy viscosity
might be written as u times l.
So u is distance per time.
l is distance.
So it's distance
squared per time.
So that has units of viscosity.
And the way to interpret
this is basically
sort of swirling around
eddies of a size l
and a characteristic velocity u.
Another way to write
this would be that it's l
squared over 2
times a timescale.
Because we often
write diffusion,
if there's a time step
tau, and a length scale
l for a given step, then
l squared over 2 tau
is the diffusivity.
That's how we think about
molecular diffusivity as well.
But the question is,
what is this timescale.
So we can see here that
the timescale is l over u.
So it's a convective
times scale.
It's the time to, essentially,
go around one of those eddies.
And I'm writing these really
just as scaling arguments here.
So if we look at
these flows, what
are the relevant length scales?
So at the beginning
of this flow here,
it's the length scale
is that of the object.
In the case of the
breathing, the length scale
is initially that of
the mouth opening.
But then we form these turbulent
structures that expand.
And a constant we
will return to you
shortly is that
the relevant length
scale as you continue
here is actually something
which depends on position.
So as this thing
grows the eddies
are are getting
bigger and bigger,
and so also is faster and faster
the transport by diffusion,
which sort of maintains a
fairly uniform concentration
across that space.
And that brings us then to
what happens in the whole room.
So we've been very interested
in mixing in the whole room.
And so a natural picture
here is to say, well,
if the room has a height H,
then the eddy diffusivity,
which aerosol
particles in the room
are feeling as long as it's a
fairly well mixed turbulent,
more isotropic flow, could be
described as the height squared
over 2 times a timescale.
And the timescale should be
that of the effective air
change or the total air
change time, basically.
So this here,
again, I've written
lambda bar a is
the outer airflow
plus the re-circulation
airflow, which
may be going through a filter,
and divided by the total volume
of the room.
So this is the total ACH.
And so what we see here then
is that the formula is roughly
that we should have 1/2
H squared lambda a bar.
And so this is a very simple
argument based on the largest
eddy is going to be,
in a well mixed room,
at the size of the
scale of the room.
And sure enough,
this relationship
has actually been verified for
houses and actual indoor rooms
with all the furniture
in them, where
it's been shown
that if you release
a passive tracer such as
carbon dioxide in the middle
of the room and you
have the ventilation
on at a certain ACH, Air Change
per Hour, lambda a bar, then
this formula, even
with the 1/2 actually,
turns out to be a pretty good
approximation for the spreading
in that room as you change
the size of the room
and look at different rooms
and also look at different air
change rates.
So that's, I think, a good
starting point for us as well.
At least when the
room is well mixed,
this is a good way to think
about transport in the room.
Also, we see from this picture
that the timescale for mixing
is the inverse of
the air change time.
So the mixing time is also
comparable to the residence
time of the air,
including re-circulation.
So basically it's
the time it takes
for air to typically
go through this system
is also the time it takes to
fully mix the system, roughly
the same order of magnitude.
And that is the characteristic
of a well mixed turbulent room
which could occur by
any of the mechanisms
we've just been describing.
Although the same principles
also apply to jets or strong,
maybe ventilation flows past
an object where you might still
have some heterogeneities
as I've sketched here,
that we will need to consider.
The last point I'd
like to come back to
also is the question
of sedimentation.
So you may have
found it surprising
that we describe the flux
of sedimenting particles
to the ground in
a very simple way
by just using the
Stokes velocity, vs,
and multiplying by the area.
So we said the droplet
flux out of the room
was just the sedimentation
velocity of the droplet, which
was radius dependent, times the
area, the floor surface area.
And what's a bit confusing
about that at first
is that we know the flows
are very complex in the room.
In fact, if you look at
dust particles in a room
as we discussed earlier
in some cases, for sure,
you will see them actually
rising and not settling.
So they may be settling
relative to the flow.
But the flow is actually
convecting them upwards.
And that's here,
for example, if you
look at there's a
dominant role in the flow
that I've sketched here.
The particles over
here actually might
have a net velocity going up.
And over here,
they're going down.
But if you decompose
that velocity field, then
in some cases, they're going
up due to flow or convection,
while they're sedimenting
at the rate vs.
But then necessarily,
because the fluid
is approximately incompressible
and is returning somewhere--
wherever it goes up, somewhere
else it's coming down,
we find that in other
areas you have vs still
pointing down with the same rate
and now the flow is going down.
And if you imagine
a particle that
is sampling all the
different velocity vectors,
the blue vectors,
sometimes they're up,
sometimes they're
down, on average
the blue velocity vectors of
the flow have to average to 0.
Because there's no--
or at least near 0.
There's not, let's
say, a very strong
vertical relative motion.
Then it's reasonable to
assume that the particles will
sediment out of a well mixed
turbulent flow at a rate given
by vsa.
And that is something
that has also
been validated experimentally
for well mixed chambers
and rooms.